well in light of today's verdict in
minneapolis
all the sports leagues issued statements
some nfl teams posted on social media in
regards to the event
the raiders posted this on social media
this afternoon
and they were absolutely getting crushed
on the social platform there are over 65
000 retweets and 27 000 mentions many
critical of the post
we spoke with raiders owner mark davis
this afternoon he's telling us
that this was indeed his tweet he's not
going to delete it but he says in no way
shape or form did he mean to disrespect
the floyd family
he says that three words were taken from
floyd's brother
philonus who said this following the
verdict i get dms
people from brazil from ghana from
germany
everybody london italy they're all
saying the same thing
we won't be able to breathe until you're
able to breathe
today we are able to breathe again
because
justice for judge means freedom for all
all right now last may shortly after the
killing of george floyd davis wrote this
to watch a man be murdered
by a uniformed police officer kneeling
on the man's throat for nine minutes
while three
uniformed police officers either
assisted or stood by watching is
disturbing in so many ways
to be honest david says i'm surprised
that the resulting violence hasn't been
worse
emotions are high the temperature is hot
they're static in the air but burning
your brother's house down
is ultimately not the answer not only do
we have to tell people there is
something wrong
we have to come up with solutions that's
the challenge in front of us not only as
americans but as human beings